what stands between Africa's current
prostrate condition and the future of
prosperity and abundance for its
long-suffering populations one word
knowledge if Africa is to become a
continent that offers the best life for
humans it must become a knowledge
society immediately this is what I have
called Africa's knowledge imperative our
universities must reduce emphasis on
producing manpower for running our civil
society our economy and our political
institutions they should be dedicated
mainly to knowledge production what
sense is there in producing civil
engineers who are not supported by soil
scientists and geologists who make it
their business to create knowledge about
our soil and our rocks what use is there
in producing lawyers without jurists who
produce knowledge of the underlying
philosophy cofounders of the legal
system we must seek knowledge we must
approach the matter of knowledge with a
maniacal commitment without let or
hindrance though we must seek knowledge
to solve problems we know of we must
also seek knowledge when there is no
problem in view especially when there's
no problem in view we must seek to know
as much of what there is to know of all
things
limited only by the insufficiency of our
human nature and not only when the need
arises those who do not seek knowledge
when it is not needed will not have it
when they must have it
the biggest crisis in Africa today is
the crisis of knowledge how to produce
it how to manage it and how to deploy it
effectively for instance Africa does not
have a water crisis it has in knowledge
crisis regarding its water where and
what type it is how it can be tapped and
made available where and when needed to
all and sundry how does a continent that
is home to some of the largest bodies of
water in the world denial the niger the
congo the Zambezi and the orange rivers
be said to have a water crisis including
in countries where those rivers are and
that is only surface water while we are
only dissipate our energies fighting the
wrong crisis
others who invest in knowledge about us
are busy figuring out how to pipe water
from Libya's aquifers to quench Europa's
first such is our knowledge of our water
resources that many of our countries
have given up on making potable water in
routine presence in the lives of
Africans rich or poor high and low rural
and urban we eagerly accept what the
merchants of misery in the Global
African Studies Safari professorial
and their aid adult autonomy fearing
African minions in government
universities and civil society tell us
regarding how nature has been to Stinton
towards Africa when it comes to the
distribution of water resources in the
world we are content to run our cities
and rural aliens alike on boreholes
how does one run metropolises on
boreholes and wells
thus africa have a food crisis again the
answer is no it is
yet another knowledge crisis regarding
Africa's agricultural resources what and
where they are and how they can be best
money to make Africans live more lives
that I was living otherwise how does one
explain the fact that dog Rafi puts a
source of the River Nile in Ethiopia and
its people cannot have water for their
lives and the same geography puts
California in the desert but it is a
breadbasket the difference obviously is
not geography it is knowledge
Colorado's aquifers grow California's
pistachios
why can't Libya's aquifers grow Sodom in
northern Nigeria why does Nigeria not
aspire to feed the world not just itself
if Africa's land is so poor as we are
often told why are outsiders from the
United Arab Emirates all the way to
South Korea burn up vast acreages of our
land to grow food no less to feed their
people in lands that are truly more
geographically stinking the new land
owners are not planning to import new
topsoil to media African acquisitions
more arable again a singular instance of
knowledge deficiency in the 19th century
our predecessors just years removed from
the ravages of slavery and the slave
trade while exploring the Niger and
Congo rivers with a view to turning
Africa's resources to the advantage of
its people and to the rest of humanity
and the 20th century successors were
dreaming of harnessing the powers of the
river Congo to light of the whole
continent now only Buccaneer capitalists
from Europe are skimming of doing the
same but for export to Europe and South
Africa and they are even suggesting that
Congolese may not benefit from this
scheme
because according to them Congolese
communities are too small to me
providing them with electricity a viable
concern the solution Africa must become
a knowledge society the defining
characteristic of the modern age we
neither are nor are we on the path to
becoming in knowledge society since have
not always been this way when it comes
to knowledge production and Africa in
antiquity the world went to Africa for
intellectual enrichment there were
celebrated centers of learning
attracting questions from all parts of
the then known world seeking knowledge
about that world what happened then has
implications for a present for example
how Roman Africa managed the
relationship between settlers and
natives between the 2nd and 4th
centuries of our era might have
something to teach us when it comes to
confronting not too dissimilar problems
at the present time but how many
classics departments do we have in our
universities because we do not invest in
knowledge people come to Africa now not
as a place of intellectual enrichment
but as a place where they sit there
first for exotica yet for the last half
millennium Africa has been hemorrhaging
and exporting knowledge to the rest of
the world regardless of the popular
description of it as a trade embodies
the European transatlantic slave trade
and slavery was one of the most radical
and longest programs of African Bryn's
export in history American slave owners
may have pretended that Africans were
mere brute beasts of burden almost as
inert and Dom as other farm implements
they classified them with in their
Ledger's and that's what they did
the enslaved Africans on the other hand
knew there were embodiments of knowledge
there was myths there were ports your
political counselors there were princes
and princesses
there were metallurgist the waha
biologists UI chefs the list is endless
there to take a simple example brought
the knowledge of rice cultivation to the
American South they created some of the
most original civilizational elements
for which the United States is now
celebrated they deploy their knowledge
for the most part without compensation
for the last half millennium beginning
with the slave trade Africa has been
exploiting brains while simultaneously
breaking the chains of knowledge
transmission on the continent itself
with their consequences for the systems
of knowledge production in Africa
successful generations are cut off from
the intellectual production of their
predecessors we keep producing for
external markets while bettering our own
internal needs as present much of the
best knowledge about Africa is neither
produced nor housed there even when it
is produced by Africans because we are
dominated by immediate needs and
relevant solutions when it comes to what
we should know
we are happy to hand over to others the
responsibility to produce knowledge
including knowledge about of unfroze and
to do so far away from us we are ever
eager to consume knowledge and have what
in a portion of it without any anxiety
about ownership and location African
universities are now all too content to
have 8 connections with libraries
elsewhere
having given up ambitions on building
libraries to which the world will come
for intellectual edification control
over who decides what should be stopped
on our shelves
and how access to collections should be
determined are made to rest on our trust
in our partners good faith that they
will not abandon us down the road this
must change Africa must become a place
of knowledge again knowledge production
actually expands the economy take appear
logical digs for instance and their
impact on tourism our desire to unearth
our antiquity especially those remote
times of which we have no written
records requires investment in ecology
and related disciplines eg pineal
anthropology yet although it is our past
we seek to know by sheer serendipity
archeology may shed light on the global
human experience and yield economic
payoffs there were no part of the
original reasons for diggin we must find
a way to make knowledge and its
production sexy and rewarding rewarding
not in the crass sense of money-making
but in terms of making it worthwhile to
indulge in the pursuit of knowledge
support the existence of knowledge
producing groups and intellectuals
ensuring that the continent becomes the
immediate locus of knowledge production
distribution and consumption and that
instead of having its depositories
beyond Africa's boundaries people once
more come from the rest of the world
even if in virtual space to learn from
us all this we do as custodians on
behalf of common humanity creating a
knowledge society in Africa for me would
be one way to celebrate and
simultaneously enhance diversity by
infinitely originate with material and
additional artifacts artifacts that we
furnish by hours
drivings in the knowledge field thank
you very much
[Applause]